الصين تحدث طبعا داخل حلف شمال الاطلسي
بشان كيفيه تعامل الحلف مع بكين بحسب
صحيفه بوليتيكو الامريكيه اذا الدوريه
اشارت الى ان الخلافات حاده داخل الناتو
حياه الصين التي اعتبرها الحلف تحديا في
وقت سابقا من هذا العامه
لكن لم يتفقوا على كيفيه التعامل وطبيعه
العلاقات معها
تقرا اشار الى وجود تباينات داخل نيته بين
الصقور الذين لا يريدون اعداء بكين بشكل
مفرط والحمائم الذين يتحدثون عن الاعتماد
الاقتصادي على الصين
الولايات المتحده يحاولون الموازنه بين
اهداف النيتو ورغبتهم في تقييد التكيين
وعلى الطرف الاخر دول مثل المجر التي تريد
التخفيف من اللهجه الصين في هذا الاطار
نقلت بوليتيكو عن السفيره الامريكيه
جوليان سميث قولها ان استراتيجيات
الولايات المتحده يمكن ان تكون متوافقه
الا انها اعترفت ان ترجمه اقوال الحلف الى
افعال لقد تحتاجه وقت اطول
مساله ما اذا كانت الصين تستحق الكثير من
الاهتمام في الوقت الحالي في وقت تدور
راحه الحرب الاوكرانيه في الفناء
على طاوله ده راي خارجيه دول النت ويومي
الثلاثاء والاربعاء في العاصمه الرومانيه
بوخارستيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف ان
اوروبا لديها ما يكفي من التهديدات
والتحديات في السيناريو التقليدي للحلف
واوضح انه لم يتم وضع تصورا لعمليات
الناتو في المحيط الهادئ لانه تحالف شمال
الاطلسي واضاف ان الاتحاد او على الاتحاد
الاوروبي والنيتو الا يخفى لا التحديدات
التحديات والتحديدات الاخرى التي تواجه
التكتلينا
مجله فوري بوليسيه
لها ان المانيا تقود اهداف الوحده الغربيه
تجاه الصين
منذ بدايه رائحه كورونا عندما وصلها في
زياره خاطفه امتدت 11 ساعه فقط في الرابعه
من الشهر الجاري و سبق جونس زيارته للصين
بمقال في بوليتكو اعتبر فيها انه حتى في
ظل ظروف المتغيره تظل الصين شريكا تجاريا
مهما لالمانيا واوروبا ولا يمكن الانفصال
عنه
داخل الاحتراف الحاكم في المانيا عندما
اعترض وزراء الخارجي انا لينابير بوك
والماليه روبرت هابيك وهما من حزب الخضر
على الاتفاقات المعقوده خلال اللقاء بين
برلين وتاكيد وقال الوزيران ان على
المانيا التوقف عن قبول ما وصفاه
بالابتزاز الصينيه
ترك بلقائه في بكين انطباعا قويا لان
اولوياته هي تعزيز العلاقات الاقتصاديه
لالمانيا مع الصين ما قد يضع المانيا في
موقع تكون فيه الحلقه الاضعف في التحالف
الغربي وقد تسعى الصين لاستغلال ذلك
الاوروبيه خادم قاربات موحده نحو الصين
حول الرئيس الصيني السجن التعامل مع
القاده الاوروبيين في مجموعه العشرين في
سوره منفرده مع تجنب اي لقاء رسمي مع
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ورئيس المجلس
الاوروبي